i'm told that as a youth not that you're
an old man now
but as a younger man you uh you really
love the movie fight club and you
started your own fight club i did yeah
it's very embarrassing i was very
inspired by that movie
but both plus we were talking before
small town
indiana so there's not really a lot to
do other than
um you know go to the movies and
kick the [ __ ] out of each other
and so there was like a a building
called
celebrations unlimited that was by my
friend noah's house
that has um it's like an event space for
for mishawaka
so it's very small for what they
intended for celebrations unlimited
let's go to celebrations unlimited and
beat each other senseless
until you know we would go back there
but through noah's
fence to the celebrations unlimited
backyard and and fight each other and
whoever rode by on their bikes and
so anyone could be riding by on their
bike and then they could join and then
you guys
were fighting each other oh i'll fight
you guys and then we'd find them you
know this is just like the movie
how would it resolve itself did you
fight until someone was knocked
knocked down yeah well until someone
said that you know ow or i don't want to
do it anymore
or crying crying the first one to cry
loses
uh what about uh you oscar were you a
bit of a troublemaker growing up
yeah is that fair to say yeah i was i
was i was a bit of a troublemaker i
think in uh
in elementary school they ended up
because there was too much of a
distraction they ended up putting me in
the back of the class and they put one
of those uh
you know the things that you put in a
windshield and a car to stop the sun
from coming in
yeah so they put that around my desk
which was a grind shield around they
blocked you from the other
the other kids put me in the back i mean
i i ended up getting expelled as well
from another school
for like just doing silly things like
spraying a fire extinguisher
i think it's inspirational to a lot of
young people watching that
you were beating others in a parking lot
you were
you know just a troublemaker at school
they probably look like they put a
bucket on your head
that i do from other you're being
expelled and now you guys look what
you're doing this is fantastic
this is a great message for young people
yeah do whatever you want it's going to
work out in the end
you'll be in star wars yeah you want to
be a star wars
it's nice of you guys to come in and
hang with us yeah in this really
creepy theater you know